He was the communist hardliner
with a softer side.
Jiang Zemin was also a shrewd
and cunning politician.
He rose to the pinnacle of power
after the massacre
of pro-democracy
demonstrators in Tiananmen
Square in 1989.
He didn't order the crackdown,
but was handpicked by the man wh
Supreme Leader Deng Xiaoping.
A year after the bloodshed,
Jiang Zemin told America's ABC N
it was, quote, much ado about no
At first,
he was written off
by most as a political lightweig
who wouldn't last.
He was known as the flower pot.
Lots of decoration and no action
But history would prove them wro
Jiang Zemin has had many more su
and failures,
and he's surprised
many people with his staying pow
as leader.
He quoted the military
and was determined
to keep the communists in power
while pushing ahead
with economic reforms.
He's definitely
not going to be remembered as
China's Gorbachev. He's not even
on an official U.S.
visit in 1997.
Jiang was lauded by Wall Street
and chastised by
President Bill Clinton over huma
rights on this issue.
We believe the policy of the gov
is on the wrong side of history.
But he never gave ground
on political reforms
and explained
why during a rare interview with
I do think that to require all c
to adopt
the same model of democracy
would itself be undemocratic.
He was leader when Hong Kong was
back to the mainland,
when Beijing was awarded the Oly
and businesspeople were allowed
to become communists.
In 2003, he retired as president
The year after that,
he gave up his last post
as China's military commander,
completing the first smooth
leadership transition ever
in communist China.
So I want to thank you
for accepting my resignation,
he said at the time.
Jiang still exerted
political influence
behind the scenes for years,
including the selection of curre
Chinese leader Xi Jinping,
who secured a norm
busting third term as party head
Xi, China's most powerful leader
in decades,
has eviscerated political rivals
including those in Jang's factio
and rolled back much of the econ
and personal freedoms
enjoyed during the Jiang era
in retirement.
Jiang reportedly sang an aria
at Beijing's National Grand Thea
before it was officially opened
for a man who once ruled
more than a billion people.
The performance was said
to be the fulfillment
of a lifetime ambition
for